die ganze welt schaut auf diesen zaun
die grenzen europas tausende wollen
reihen von belarus nach polen weiter
nach deutschland und einige dutzend
flüchtlinge haben es auch in dieser
nacht geschafft sie haben den massiven
grenzzaun von belarus nach polen
überwunden geknackt viele von ihnen sind
jetzt in der eu und hunderte flüchtlinge
wollen folgen sind direkt an diesem zaun
in den wäldern in der kälte und
mittendrin unsere bild-reporter ja so
lange wie niemand anderes dran an dieser
neuen flüchtlingskrise wir zeigen ihnen
einmal bilder die von unseren reportern
in den vergangenen stunden gedreht
wurden direkt dort im grenzgebiet von
belarus nach polen beeindruckende bilder
aus den wäldern aus der kälte wie sie
sehen das sind jetzt nächte in denen die
temperatur runtergehen unter null grad
wir sehen erschöpfte flüchtlinge dort in
den wäldern im niemandsland also dort wo
das gebiet weder zu groß noch zu polen
gehört direkt am zaun eben in der nacht
werden dort feuer gemacht große camps
dort aber auch das blaue licht sehen sie
flackern dahinter also die fahrzeuge der
grenzpolizei und auch soldaten ja
mittlerweile dort im einsatz also dass
die frischen bilder die teilweise von
den flüchtlingen selbst stammen und eben
auch in der nacht und am tag in den
vergangenen stunden gedreht wurden von
unseren bild reportern im einsatz dort
für sie an der grenze von belarus nach
polen wo sich dieses neue
flüchtlingsdrama aktuell abspielt und
auch dieses foto ging in den vergangenen
stunden um die welt das
soll das foto von flüchtlingsjungen
redest ahmad über ihn sprechen wir
gleich noch denn wir haben mit ihm
gesprochen zunächst scheint mir aber
einmal hier das ist der junge 14 jahre
alt germany germany das ist sein
erklärtes ziel unsere reporter die haben
auch mit ihm gesprochen diesen beitrag
zeigen wir ihnen gleich zunächst aber
war live gehen zu unseren reportern an
der grenze peter wilke in der nacht kam
es dort zu einem durchbruch einige
flüchtlinge haben es immer geschafft von
belarus nach polen wie ist die situation
jetzt dort
patricia wir stehen hier direkt an eben
dieser sperrzone kurz vor krimi einem
der grenzorte hier an der grenze von
polen zu petrus und eben in krinke dort
in der nähe sind in der letzten namen
flüchtlinge durchgebrochen das wurde so
mitgeteilt eben in krinke und einem
anderen ort es soll sich um dutzende
flüchtlinge handeln manche wurden schon
bereits direkt vor ort festgenommen
andere sollen immer noch auf freiem fuß
eben jetzt hier in polen unterwegs sein
und verstecken sich vermutlich eben
hinter uns erst sind jetzt freie felder
zu sehen aber hier rum ringsherum sind
viele viele große dichte wälder dort
drinnen werden sich sie sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich verstecken und dann geben
sich vor der polizei vor den polnischen
würden
schützen denn die würden sie direkt
wieder zurück nach belarus bringen und
eben in dieser schutz suchen die mit
versuchen heimlich in richtung
deutschland vor zu kommen um eben da ein
sicheres ziel zu suchen wie rigoros die
polizei vorgeht das haben wir hier
gerade auch erfahren wie jetzt
journalisten dürfen ja eben nicht in
diese schmerzen rein wir haben uns heute
einfach mal dieser sperrzone genährt mit
unserem auto sind herangefahren hier
wurde über kein schild zu sehen hier
wurde nicht ausgeschildert dass es sich
um eine station behandelt deswegen sind
wir bis zu den ersten check point dem
man hier im hintergrund sehen kann
gefahren ihr werden die autos
kontrolliert auch wir wurden eben
kontrolliert und da wurden wir sehr
ruppig angegangen da wurde uns auf
einmal gedroht so ihr werdet jetzt hier
festgenommen ihr kommt jetzt in haft
weil ihr dürft hier nicht sein später
hat sich dann herausgestellt dass das wo
er eine abschreckungsmaßnahmen warum uns
an zu machen jetzt dürfen wir eben
berichten aber vollkommen willkürlich
vollkommen ohne grund wurde in dem eine
festnahme angedroht wurden wir über
minuten 10 bis 20 minuten eine kontrolle
verwickelt obwohl wir eigentlich nur
frei berichten wollen aber das ist hier
in polen an der grenze wohl nicht mehr
möglich weil man von polnischer seite
auch nicht der weltöffentlichkeit zeigen
möchte zumindestens nicht ungefiltert
was da eben passiert eine grenze
deswegen wurde eben dieses sperrgebiet
dort eingerichtet auch auf polnischer
seite wir wollen aber in diesem
grenzgebiet noch einmal bleiben bei
unserem bild chefreporter kollegen hans
jörg vehlewald die grenze von belarus
nach polen die es rund 400 kilometer
lang und entlang dieser strecke haben
wir uns reporter eben in diesen tagen
platziert haben beschreibt einmal wo du
bist von dir stammten diese ja
beeindruckenden bilder aus den
vergangenen stunden von dort erschöpften
von vor allen dingen frierenden
flüchtlingen im wald beschreiben uns
einmal wo und was du dort erlebt hast
also stehe hier in einem ort namens rest
gar das ist ungefähr 56 kilometer
entfernt von der grenze zu belarus auch
hier hat es in der nacht oder gestern
abend wohl einen durchbruch gegeben
wie bei bioware ja so heißt der ort
direkt an der grenze und unter zelten
mit anwohner hier dass sie heute morgen
auch tatsächlich vier bis fünf dieser
flüchtlinge gesehen haben die
durchgebrochen sind inzwischen wurden
aber offensichtlich alle wieder zurück
zur grenze gebracht wieder
zurückgeschoben nach belarus das hier
ist ein ort in dem eigentlich regelmäßig
die flüchtlinge die ist rüber schaffen
über die grenze an landen in den wäldern
wir stehen hier vor im birkenwald in
diesem wald campieren tatsächlich immer
wieder flüchtlinge so wie wir gestern
eben auch gestern nachmittag kontakt
hatten zu 16 flüchtlingen aus wie sie
selber sagen kurdistan aus dem nord-irak
die hatten es tatsächlich vor 16 tagen
geschafft über die grenze rüberzukommen
das erste mal und sind immer wieder hin
und her geschoben worden zurückgeschoben
worden von dem polnischen grenze dann
wieder zurück von der belarussischen
seite von soldaten sie berichteten wohl
auch dass sie das ihnen tatsächlich
immer wieder auch ein loch in den zaun
geschnitten wurde von den belarussischen
soldaten die sie einfach loswerden
wollen diese richtung westen schicken
wollen um polen um die eu in probleme zu
bringen die jetzt hier tatsächlich
spürbar sind ein zwerg welche hilfen
erreichen denn diese menschen mich
berührt auch besonders die bilder der
kinder dort in dieser eiseskälte welche
hilfen erreichen diese menschen denn
überhaupt konkret
das kommt immer darauf an auf wen sie
denn da eigentlich stoßen das erste ist
wie gestern bei der gruppe der 16 kurven
eine ganze großfamilie drei generationen
die hatten das glück zunächst einmal auf
helfer darauf flüchtlingshelfer hier zu
stoßen die sich zusammengetan haben um
den menschen tatsächlich akut zu helfen
ihnen einfach decken zu bringen etwas
für die für die babys kindernahrung zu
bringen festes schuhwerk zu bringen
viele von denen haben ganz einfach keine
schuhe mehr muss sich vorstellen es ist
wirklich gefrorener boden
in der nacht wird es minus 3 45 grad und
die haben teilweise wirklich keine
schuhe an das heißt sie werden erstmal
erstversorgt mit warmen klamotten mit
mit etwas zu trinken etwas zu essen die
gruppe gestern die kurden die hatten
seit drei tagen nichts mehr gegessen die
nahrung war einfach ausgegangen ihre
vorräte waren ausgegangen das heißt dort
werden sie erstversorgt und was dann in
der regel passiert ist dass die
grenzpolizei die hier wirklich
allgegenwärtig ist auch uns war sie
gestern immer wieder auf der spur dass
dann die grenzpolizisten kommen und
tatsächlich in
ange dutzend soldaten dann kommen um sie
erst mal zurück zu bringen entweder ein
aufnahmelager aber meistens dann doch
direkt zur grenze und sie dort ganz
einfach wieder im wald auszusetzen
das heißt minimale hilfe von der
grenzpolizei wenn sie glück haben etwas
mehr hilfe hier von den anwohnern die
auch regelmäßig sammeln die wirklich
nahrung und kleidung sammeln um diese
erstaufnahme die erste die erste
versorgung zu gewährleisten
aber insgesamt zeigt die ganze region
tausende soldaten hier unterwegs sind
wir wollen euch hier nicht haben
tausende soldaten grenzpolizisten die
mittlerweile dort allgegenwärtig sind
sagst du hansjörg das ist auch die
erfahrung die unser bild reporter
kollege peter hell gerade macht im
grenzgebiet von litauen der dort gerade
in diesen minuten so hören wir
festgesetzt wurde der im moment dort an
der berichterstattung gehindert wird aus
diesem grenzgebiet wir versuchen gerade
noch in erfahrung zu bringen was genau
dort los ist und ob wir in einigen
minuten dann mit peter hell doch
widersprechen können dort vor ort eben
in dem grenzgebiet von litauen wir gehen
aber jetzt erst mal an die vorläufige
endstation der die durchkommen dann
durch den zaun durch polen wir gehen zu
unserer kollegin jasmin yavuz die in
görlitz steht wo wir noch die
schrecklichen bilder im kopf haben ein
transporter mit einer leiche gefunden
wurde das ist gerade mal zehn tage her
jasmin kommen immer mehr flüchtlinge
nach görlitz oder ist das wenn wir von
unseren kollegen gerade hören das sehr
strikt kontrolliert wird mittlerweile
dass viele soldaten viele
grenzpolizisten im einsatz sind ist es
dieser strom erst mal gestoppt
also weiterhin kommen hier natürlich
auch flüchtlinge hin doch über die
aktuelle lage kann natürlich vor allem
die bundespolizei etwas sagen bei der
ich gerade stehe und neben mir steht
sprecher der bundespolizei marcel brands
hatch wie ist denn die aktuelle lage
spitzt es sich zu kommen immer mehr was
erleben ja also die bundespolizei hier
im sächsisch polnischen grenzraum hat
vermehrt mit dem phänomen der
einschleusung von personen belarus polen
nach deutschland zu tun wir stellen das
seit anfang august fest dass wir hier
vermehrt personen die diesen reiseweg
dieses gute genutzt haben feststellen
wenn sich die zahlen vom august im
september noch verdoppelt haben so haben
sie sich aktuell vom september zum
oktober verdreifacht und allein anfang
november haben mit die feststellung von
knapp 400 allein schon wieder
festgestellten unerlaubt eingereisten
personen und am letzten wochenende waren
dort gestern man es allein auch 100
sie bringen die flüchtlinge dann hierzu
bundespolizei dort werden sie
erkennungsdienstlich behandelt und dann
geht es in die erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen
aber wir haben eben schon gehört es gab
auch einen traurigen einzelfall momentan
ein flüchtling wurde tot geborgen
in welchen zuständen kommen denn die
menschen hier an die migranten was
können sie dazu sagen das ist ganz
unterschiedlich wir haben personen die
einem erschöpften zustand sind die
gegebenenfalls durchnässt sind sie sind
gegen jedenfalls gesundheitlich
angeschlagen hier muss dann auch der
rettungsdienst immer wieder hinzugezogen
werden um eine begutachtung der personen
durchführen zu können und wir haben
natürlich auch das phänomen dass die
person einfach durch diese reise
gezeichnet sind und hier erst mal die
möglichkeit haben frische sachen zu
bekommen an nahrung zu und flüssigkeit
zu sich nehmen zu können und das wird
auch in anspruch genommen das ist immer
im drk mit dem austausch da sonst hier
die
sachen zur verfügung stellte sie als
bundespolizei können der lage noch herr
werden ja wir reagieren auf die lage
davon dass wir unser personal
entsprechend anpassen wir zusätzliches
personal zum einsatz bringen in dem
sinne dass die mobile kontrollen
überwachungseinheit der
bundespolizeidirektion pirna und die
bundesbereitschaftspolizei uns hier in
den dienst stellen ludwigshof und
ebersbach unterstützen und insofern sind
wir gut gewappnet
wunderbar vielen dank herr brett ja
soweit die aussagen von der
bundespolizei in görlitz wir werden die
lage natürlich auch hier vor ort weiter
beobachten und damit gebe ich gerne
zurück